Todd Chrisley's son Kyle facing a legal
battle of his own after being arrested
in Tennessee Tuesday I would love to say
it's all scripted but you can't script
the dysfunction that goes on and off a
spokesperson for the Rutherford County
Sheriff's Department confirmed Kyle was
arrested for aggravated assault he was
booked into an adult detention center
and later released on a three thousand
dollar Bond
the charges against Kyle come two months
after his dad began serving his 12-year
sentence in federal prison for tax
evasion and fraud Todd's wife Julie is
currently serving seven years it sounds
like your faith has really pulled all of
you through so many turbulent times God
he knows how you're going to get through
it and I believe that this was a test of
our character it was a test of our faith
it was a test of our commitment to each
other tensions have run High between
Todd and his son for some time before
going behind bars Todd and Julie were
raising Kyle's daughter Chloe
hello hello
how are you
Chloe she has been adopted she is ours
she is our daughter she is not our
granddaughter this all amid Kyle's
struggle with addiction I went through a
really dark place in my life I came out
of it when Chloe was born I love her so
much I just know down in my heart that I
have to do this for her but if I need to
be the one to step up and put a foot in
Kyle's ass and keep him moving in order
for Chloe to have a good role model then
Kyle and I are going to keep doing that
dance Todd and Kyle have also spoken out
about their estrangement you've done a
lot of things Kyle
that have hurt you and that have hurt
the family yeah I mean so you know that
I cannot welcome you back into our
family until I know that you're where
you need to be yeah I want my family
back but before Todd surrendered to
prison he and Kyle made amends you know
that I love you yeah and I would want
nothing nothing more than that Kyle has
come to us and he has asked for
forgiveness and you know he has
struggled with drugs and he's clean and
he's doing doing the best that he's done
and I can't tell you how long
details regarding Kyle's arrest were not
made immediately available he's due in
court on March 20th
foreign